[Applause]
football may be back but the looming
threat of omicron is undoing the premier
league schedule six out of ten matches
this weekend were cancelled and managers
now want a pause to the whole season
that's why i'm not against stopping the
league
i just don't see
the 100 benefit of it we think that we
should postpone the full round of
premier league games this weekend coming
up
the
the covet cases are going through the
roof in all the premier league clubs we
were just worried about the safety of
players the players were concerned about
their health because we had several
positive covey tests in several for in
consecutive days
despite the warnings after high-level
talks today the premier league decided
not to postpone the season you start to
look at the logistical nightmare in
terms of fixture congestion if games get
called off and there's no real guarantee
that this proposed circuit breaker and
indeed i i'm not certain that the
circuit breaker would have been
something that would have helped
um because you there's no guarantee that
in two weeks time or however long the
proposed circuit breaker was you'd be
out of this
but matches are already affected
tottenham's sunday game against
liverpool was their first in a fortnight
and where games do happen there are
warnings that healthy players are being
overused while others isolate pausing
the whole of the premier league would
have had huge implications this is a
busy schedule with very little slack
even moving matches by a week or two
would have been really hard to manage
not to mention the financial
implications that come with postponing
matches i think we're going to see
further games postponed and clearly that
that then has an impact on immediate
match day revenue and in some cases
possibly on broadcasting reviews if
there are a lot of if there's any long
breaks then new sponsors become
concerned because they're not getting
value for money from their sponsorship
as matches are moved across the english
game there has been criticism that not
enough players are vaccinated today the
bristol city squad were among those
taken for their boosters and we are a
long way from the empty stadiums of last
year there are currently 30 premier
league matches due to happen over
christmas in the new year
there is little consensus and festive
and football cheer is still at the mercy
of covid
ali forskew sky news